all right let's take some questions from
our audience hey jason big fan what's
your opinion on the ray ban facebook
collaboration okay i don't trust
facebook
you shouldn't trust facebook
and based on the facebook leaks uh and
the facebook papers i think we're all
going to come to the conclusion that
they are not taking uh their role in
society and the footprint and the impact
they have seriously
to use any of their hardware products
that have a microphone or camera you
would have to be absolutely out of your
mind
to put anything facebook related on your
mobile phone uh on your glasses
that um
portal they had uh where they had the
muppets i think doing commercials for it
is absolutely crazy do not put any
facebook devices in your home
in fact i'm thinking i took facebook off
my phone a while ago you know i use
instagram because i kind of like it and
i got a lot of friends on it
but yeah it's kind of hard to give up
isn't it it's hard to extract yourself
the thing i did to really extract myself
is i used to use facebook connect to log
into everything because it was so
convenient i stopped that i disconnected
facebook connect you know it went into
my settings turned off all
authentications i never ever ever log in
with facebook connect i wouldn't do that
and i would never ever buy those glasses
and i would never buy their portal or
whatever their you know interactive tool
is i think people are going to start
voting with their time and just getting
off of
social media in general is a good idea
and spend more time with your friends
and family all right next question hey
jason what are your favorite sas
products and why well obviously we live
in slack and notion all day long
we're using restream more and more to
run the podcast and i absolutely love
that as well so
i think notions become quite a game
changer uh we like uh
zapier and if this than that as well
because it helps us build glue between
things so
uh those are some of my favorites notion
i think is really
had a great impact uh on the company and
uh squarespace i love too for
beautifully designed websites
all right next up a question what are my
thoughts on the tesla plaid um
you know uh
my wife and i are getting too many
speeding tickets with these teslas
and so
uh instead of tesla plaid and going zero
to 60 in under two seconds i have been
putting it on shell
and been putting uh a speed limiter on
the
uh all the cars we own from tesla
because i think
getting into speeding getting speeding
tickets is a bummer and getting points
on your license as a bummer
so i don't want to go any faster
i've had these teslas forever and my
lord going 0 to 60 in four seconds or
less is an absolutely crazy experience
and going in 1.9 seconds or under two
seconds like literally
the stuff that goes flying into the back
seat is crazy so it is an awesome
technological advancement
i'm tempted to buy the new model s or x
and trade in
we have an x and i was thinking about
trading it in
but i think i'm just going to a cyber
truck so that's my plan i really want
the cyber truck i think that looks
amazing and dope the the other thing i
like is really the
increasing the range so for me at this
point in my life 50 years old
i'm i'm taking the uh i'm taking the
scenic route and i like the 400 mile
battery to me 400 mile battery and the
self-driving
those uh kind of features to me are the
attractive ones in a tesla i cannot buy
a car
without autopilot anymore it's just when
i drive a car without autopilot is so
frustrating for me
to not be perfectly in the lane
perfectly distance from the person in
front of me and be able to
you know use navigation or something now
i'm not texting while i'm driving but
when you have self-driving on it's such
a smoother ride when you're going to
tahoe or sometimes i like to take the
drive down to la as opposed to flying
because it's five or six hours to drive
it's three to four hours to
fly i kind of like the long drive i like
listening to an audiobook
and clearing my mind so i just want to
have
a
400 mile range
uh would be really delightful and you
know i've been getting that 320 pretty
consistently on my model y and that's
nice for going to tahoe but to la i
gotta stop and i love the idea of not
stopping and just boom putting it in
autopilot and just
zipping down uh the five from la to san
francisco or going out to tahoe really
really great stuff okay here's a
question from samuel b how long term is
too long-term for a company that's a
very generic question um i like to with
the early stage startups you know let's
say they're in the first year or two i
like when they build a you know one-year
plan and a two-year plan uh and a
12-week plan and have all of those kind
of syncing with each other uh because
those people who make plans have a
greater chance of success i think
winging it
and not having a plan
really not a good idea
you really want to think about the
amount of runway you have how much money
you'll need to hit those uh you know
milestones i do also find that some of
the great founders do think in decades
and so thinking about hey when uber gets
to a hundred million people what would
you know the second decade look like
okay now we're gonna have the uber eats
in the delivery business we'll have the
trucking business we'll have
self-driving we'll have vetoes a lot of
what travis was doing with uber in the
first decade when he was there
you know a lot of those ideas i'm now
seeing in decade two of uber things we
talked about in years one and two he was
dead on he was talking about you know
uber freight he was talking about
self-driving uh he was talking about
vetoes he was talking about bikes and
micro mobility and taking public transit
and you know getting you from point a to
point b
helicopters all of these things were
things that travis was dabbling in and
he saw in the second decade a lot of the
things elon talked about with tesla in
the first decade
um you know are now coming true in the
second decade so i think thinking in
decades as well is an interesting one i
thought about my first decade of angel
investing and then i thought about my
second decade i'm now in my second
decade and today i launched that second
uh or the third syndicate we're doing
the sas syndicate that's a big part of
my
thinking about okay in the first decade
it was about me and
investing and my decisions on what to
invest in the second decade is about the
9 000 angel investors in my community
and how we invest together and so i've
been thinking hey how can investments be
occurring on the syndicate in the second
decade that i didn't lead that i didn't
personally say let's invest in this
company that maybe the community found
and got some amount of equity for or
cash with our scouting program the open
scouting program and then maybe uh you
know the community voting with their
dollars and saying hey you know these
hundred syndicate members
want to invest in this sas company that
the open scouts found
right so somebody in our audience of
this being startups found a company
submitted it
my team diligenced it sent it out to the
syndicate members in sas they uh decided
they wanted to invest and then you know
whether i invest or not was secondary to
the process right so i think a lot about
the process of supporting founders and
investing in them and so yeah it
permission granted to think in decades
but then to take actions every day that
maybe impact that quarter
or the next you know eight quarters so
there's good to have the big vision
moments when you go on a nice hike or
you're at the beach you're going skiing
yeah sure thinking decades for your life
but then you're gonna have to act and
look at the steps in front of you so you
don't trip right some people are so big
vision they never execute
that's not good either so it's a balance
great question
i want to welcome harry hurst you know
him as the co-ceo and co-founder of the
company if you've been on twitter over
the past year you've probably heard me
and my besties a number of which got
their beaks wet talking about all the
excitement around pipe and their
fundraising and the product they're
bringing to market i thought i'd have
harry come on and explain it to y'all
harry welcome to the program thank you
jason the people who are buying these
contracts the annualized contracts are
looking to make 10 on their money and
the person who's selling that in advance
believes they could put that capital to
work that would help grow their revenues
more than 10 is that a way to look at it
the simple math if you take for example
95 cents on the dollar and you have a
hundred thousand dollar trade can i take
ninety five thousand dollars today
invest that into say sales and marketing
for growth and generate five thousand
dollars in net new arr as a result of
investing that if the answer is yes
which i hope it is for any growing
company your cash flow break even on the
trade if not cash flow positive on the
trade and you have the net new arr and
you know better mcleod index not sure
where it is today but anywhere between
10 to 20 x on that additional 000 can be
seen as your profit on the trade so what
we're trying to do at pipe is turn
people from having a borrower's
mentality where they would traditionally
go to say a lender and borrow money to a
trader's mentality where they think that
their recurring revenue streams as an
asset all right thanks again harry for
coming on the pod and explaining that
with pipe.com there is no debt no loans
and most importantly to me as an angel
investor no delusion if you sign up at
pipe.com twist they'll eliminate all
your trading fees for one full year what
a generous offer pipe.com
twist so you can save up to tens of
thousands of dollars happy piping
everybody